This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。“绝对真人”。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和培养抗挫力背后的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”%，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在“Look Back at It”播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at it”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习“Learn the Hard Way”。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their eyes. own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. I am so excited to have you here back for another episode. Being an ambitious person is so obviously deeply applauded by our society.
她们把事情掌握在自己手中。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“The Girlfriends. Trust Me, Babe”。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们探讨20多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。我很高兴能邀请你回来收听另一期节目。作为一个有野心的人，显然非常深受我们社会的赞赏。
We love, we are obsessed with, we want to see success stories of people who have started businesses, who are self-made, who are entrepreneurs, authors, leaders, creators, founders, especially when they're young. But on the other side of ambition is this very real burnout and this very real struggle with how much is enough. How will I know when I'm happy? How can I balance working hard and having a life, especially in our 20s when we don't want to miss out on experience,
我们热爱，我们痴迷，我们想要看到那些白手起家、创业者、作家、领袖、创造者、创始人的成功故事，尤其是当他们还年轻的时候。但在野心的另一面，是这种非常真实的职业倦怠，以及对于“多少才算够”这种非常真实的挣扎。我怎么知道自己什么时候幸福呢？我该如何平衡努力工作和享受生活，特别是在我们20多岁的时候，我们既不想错过经历，
but we also don't want to miss out on our future or the opportunities that are presented to us. Today, I invited somebody on the podcast who knows more about this balancing act than most people. This conversation, it honestly meant a lot to me. It's really a real, it's a deep depiction of things that I'm currently working through, as you will probably hear. I am very excited by this episode. We talk about perfectionism, ambition, failure, rejection, joy and how to go after what you want deeply and passionately whilst also still allowing yourself to have a life. Without further ado, I want to introduce our lovely, beautiful, wonderful guest to the show. Amina, thank you so much for joining us. Thank you so much for
但我们也不想错过我们的未来或摆在我们面前的机会。今天，我邀请了一位比大多数人都更懂得这种平衡之道的嘉宾来到播客。这次对话对我来说真的意义重大。正如你可能会听到的那样，它确实是一个真实的、深刻的描绘，展现了我目前正在努力克服的事情。我对这一期节目感到非常兴奋。我们讨论了完美主义、野心、失败、拒绝、快乐，以及如何深入而充满激情地追求你想要的东西，同时又允许自己拥有生活。闲话少说，我想向节目介绍我们可爱、美丽、精彩的嘉宾。阿米娜，非常感谢你加入我们。非常感谢
having me, Gemma. I am so excited. Can you introduce, like, I could introduce you if you wanted me to, but I feel like you could say it better. Tell the listeners what you're about, who you are, about this book that you've written as well. Thank you so much. So I'm Amina Altai. I'm an executive coach and author and speaker. And I work with people in moments of great change around their careers and everybody from folks that are in their 20s to people that are in their 60s. And the commonality is it's people that really want to finally do work that is true to them and their soul and their calling because so many of us are just indoctrinated to work in the shoulds and do what we think our parents wanted and take the linear career path that was laid out for us. And so, you know, this work I think of as a homecoming and a way to do it
邀请我，杰玛。我太兴奋了。你能介绍一下，比如，如果你希望的话我可以介绍你，但我觉得你可以介绍得更好。告诉听众你是做什么的，你是谁，还有关于你写的那本书。非常感谢。我是阿米娜·阿尔泰。我是一名高管教练、作家和演说家。我和处于职业生涯重大变革时刻的人们一起工作，涵盖从20多岁到60多岁的每一个人。他们的共同点是，这些人真的渴望最终去做真正忠于自己、忠于内心和使命的工作，因为我们当中有太多人只是被灌输了要按“应该”去做事，去做我们认为父母希望我们做的事，并走为我们规划好的线性职业道路。所以，你知道，我认为这项工作是一种回归，一种以
in a way that is really true to who we are. And I just wrote a book. I spent two and a half years writing this book called The Ambition Trap. And I wanted to write a book about ambition because I'm a highly ambitious person and so are my clients. And it was just really expensive for me. What I noticed was that I had all these desires to grow, but it cost me a lot. It actually cost me in my health. And I tell this story in the book where I was 28 years old. I was six years into my career. And I had been working so hard, the 80-hour weeks and just the first one in, the last one out.
真正忠于我们自己的方式去做事的方法。我刚刚写了一本书。我花了两年半的时间写了这本书，名叫《野心陷阱》（The Ambition Trap）。我想写一本关于野心的书，因为我是一个野心勃勃的人，我的客户也是。这对我来说代价真的很高。我注意到的是，我有所有成长的渴望，但这让我付出了沉重的代价。它实际上损害了我的健康。我在书里讲了这个故事，当时我28岁。我的职业生涯已经进入了第六个年头。我一直工作得非常努力，每周工作80个小时，而且总是第一个到公司，最后一个离开。
And I ended up burning out and developing two autoimmune diseases. But it happened in this really dramatic fashion where I got a call from my doctor on a Friday. As I was going to work and she said, if you don't go to the hospital now instead of going to work, you'll be days away from multiple organ failure. And it's like, what 28-year-old gets that phone call, right? So, like, very early in my career, I realized my relationship to success and growth was kind of killing me. And so I had to learn another way very quickly.
我最终精疲力竭，并患上了两种自身免疫性疾病。但这件事发生得非常戏剧化，我在一个星期五接到了医生的电话。当时我正要去上班，她说，如果你现在不去医院而是去上班，你距离多器官衰竭就只有几天时间了。这就好像，哪个28岁的人会接到这样的电话，对吧？所以，在我的职业生涯早期，我意识到我对成功和成长的关系简直是在害死我。因此，我不得不非常快地学习另一种方式。
And so I went on my eat, pray love year is what I call it. And I studied all these things from coaching to mindfulness to semantics. And then eventually just felt so much better using these tools in my own life that I decided that I wanted to put it all together and teach others. And so I'm a coach and I take what I call a mind, body, and career approach to coaching so that we're really looking at all the different pieces and parts of us. And so in the book, The Ambition Trap, I'm exploring all of that, how we can have a healthy, more harmonious relationship with ambition and growth without it hurting us or others.
于是我开始了我的“吃、祈祷、爱”之旅（我这么叫它）。我研究了从教练技术到正念再到躯体学的所有这些东西。后来，在自己的生活中使用这些工具后，我感觉好多了，于是我决定把它们整合在一起并教给其他人。所以，我是一名教练，我在教练中采用我称之为“身心与职业”的方法，这样我们就能真正审视我们身上所有不同的碎片和部分。所以在书《野心陷阱》中，我正在探讨所有这些，我们如何才能与野心和成长建立一种健康、更和谐的关系，而不伤害我们自己或他人。
And that's just absolutely wild for you to say that you were 28 years old experiencing, well, about to experience multiple organ failure. And that's a shocking story. But that kind of general theme of people in their 20s, especially in this generation, pushing themselves so hard to the point of sickness and illness and disease, is not as uncommon as we might think. Let's roll it back, though. Because let's start with what exactly is the ambition trap,
对你来说，说自己28岁经历过，或者说即将经历多器官衰竭，这绝对是太疯狂了。这是一个令人震惊的故事。但这种普遍的主题——20多岁的人，尤其是这一代人，把自己逼得太紧，以至于生病、患病的现象——并不像我们想象的那么罕见。不过，让我们把时间倒回一点。因为让我们从“野心陷阱究竟是什么”开始，
because we're going to get further into these symptoms and these science a little bit later on. But how do we see the ambition trap? Firstly, what is it? How do we see it? it really showing up in our 20s. Yeah. So the ambition trap refers to the double bind that we experience around ambition. If you're a woman, a person of color, a queer person, a person with a disability, we experience
因为我们稍后会更深入地探讨这些症状和科学。但是我们该如何看待野心陷阱呢？首先，它是什么？我们该如何看待它它在我们20多岁时真正显现出来。是的。所以，野心陷阱指的是我们在野心方面经历的双重困境。如果你是一个女性、有色人种、酷儿、残疾人，我们会经历
something known as an ambition penalty, which means that we're penalized for being ambitious. It's seen as taboo for us. And so we want to take up space. We want to throw our hats in the ring for things. And often we're told to be and not to be at the very same time. And it causes a lot of tension. And so there's kind of two pieces to the ambition trap. There's the systemic piece, right, kind of operating in a system that says, hey, we don't really want you to shine and take up space. And then we internalize a lot of those messages and kind of weaponize them against
一种被称为“野心惩罚”的现象，这意味着我们因为有野心而受到惩罚。这被视为我们的禁忌。所以我们想要占据空间。我们想要为事情投掷我们的帽子（跃跃欲试）。而通常我们会同时被告知要存在又不要存在。这引起了很大的紧张。因此，野心陷阱大约有两个部分。有体制部分，对吧，有点像在一个说“嘿，我们真的不希望你发光发热并占据空间”的体制中运作。然后我们将许多这些信息内化，并有点把它们当作武器来对付
ourselves. So our own mindset is then saying, well, who are you to take up space and who are you to do the thing? And so it's this tension that we feel around growth, right? I want to grow. I want to take up space. I know I have something to contribute. But when I do, I take a hit for it. So how do we I find my right relationship with it. And honestly, this is something that I am trying to manage as well, where I feel like I was always incredibly ambitious growing up and I always wanted to do things. And then I also was kind of shamed for that a little bit and like told that I was too much. And then I also like experience the sense of like, okay, well, if you think I'm too much, I'm just going to push myself even further. And then I was the one who kind of paid the cost.
我们自己。所以我们自己的心态就会说：“嗯，你算老几，凭什么占据空间，凭什么去做这件事？”这就是我们在成长周围感受到的这种紧张感，对吧？我想成长。我想占据空间。我知道我能贡献点什么。但当我这么做时，我为此付出了代价。那么，我们如何找到与它的正确关系呢？老实说，这也是我一直在努力应付的事情，我觉得我在成长过程中一直有着惊人的野心，我总是想做事情。然后我也因此受到了一点羞辱，被告知我“太过分了”。然后我还体验到一种感觉，好吧，既然你觉得我太过分了，我只会把自己推得更远。然后我成了付出代价的那个人。
So it is like a little bit of a tightrope, tightrope to, yeah, kind of walk along. I think probably what's also contributing to this is our ideas of success as a society and what we think of ambition. It's this weird thing where sometimes you're told it's good to be ambitious and then other times you're told, no, you need to slow down. And it's like, well, what do you want for me right now? because the life of someone who is incredibly successful and who is busy all the time and everything is urgent for them, that seems to be the life that is most glamorized and most like promoted,
所以这有点像走钢丝，走钢丝，对，差不多是这样。我想，造成这种现象的原因可能还有我们作为社会对成功的看法以及我们对野心的看法。这是一种奇怪的事情，有时你被告知有野心是好的，而其他时候你被告知，不，你需要慢下来。这就像是，那你现在到底想从我这里得到什么？因为一个极其成功、整天忙碌、对他们来说一切都十万火急的人的生活，似乎是最被美化、最被推广的生活，
but it's probably not the one that's going to make us always the happiest. Can you explain how this like perception is perhaps unhealthy or contributing to some of the things that you've seen in your own work? Yes. And I want to caveat this by. saying my book is not asking anybody to be less ambitious, right? Like, I'm one of the most ambitious people I know. I bet you are too. The invitation is to find that harmonious relationship with it. But we live in a world that tells us that success is more for more's sake all the time, right? That's what ambition is. More money, more power. Always be getting the next title. Always
但它可能并不是那个总能让我们最快乐的生活。你能解释一下这种看法为什么可能是不健康的，或者它是如何导致你在自己的工作中看到的一些现象的吗？是的。我想对此进行一个附带说明，那就是我的书并没有要求任何人变得不那么有野心，对吧？就像，我是我认识的最有野心的人之一。我打赌你也是。我们的邀请是与它建立那种和谐的关系。但我们生活在一个告诉我们的世界里，成功总是为了“更多”而“更多”，对吧？这就是野心。更多的钱，更多的权力。总是争取下一个头衔。总是
be getting the next promotion. Always be stretching yourself, right? But I think that that way of being is so dysfunctional. I think it's partly what led to my developing two autoimmune diseases. And there's so many examples of how problematic that approach is out in the world, right? From celebrities to our friends, probably, because we're not supposed to be stretching and growing all the time. That more for more's sake actually costs us our health, our relationships, and even upholds oppressive systems. I think ambition goes in cycles. I think it's just like the seasons. It's like a perennial flower, right? So it's like you have this seedling of desire. You want to grow, right? I want to have this lovely podcast. I want to have this amazing career where I'm sharing beautiful things. So you water the
争取下一次晋升。总是逼迫自己，对吧？但我认为这种生存方式是非常失调的。我认为这部分导致了我患上两种自身免疫性疾病。而且这种方法有多大问题，在世界上有这么多的例子，对吧？从名人到我们的朋友，可能都有，因为我们不应该一直处于紧绷和成长的状态。为了更多而更多的这种做法实际上让我们付出了健康、人际关系的代价，甚至维护了压迫性的系统。我认为野心是有周期的。我认为它就像四季一样。它就像一朵多年生花卉，对吧？所以就像你有了欲望的幼苗。你想成长，对吧？我想拥有这个可爱的播客。我想拥有这份精彩的职业，分享美好的事物。所以你给
inner and outer environment and then it grows and you have this beautiful momentary peak in the sun, right? The petals come out. It's gorgeous. And then the seasons change and the petals fall off and we wind down and we go back underground. And maybe that ground is fallow and not doing anything until the environment is nurtured enough that we can grow again. And I think that this is such a countercultural way to think, right? I'll give you a perfect example. So I launched my book on May 13th and I had a really nice big pop for launch where I was doing all of these events. It was like that peak in the sun, right? The petals were out. I'd worked on this book for almost three. years. It's like such a peak moment. And then, you know, it's summer here in the U.S. And so I'm winding
内部和外部环境浇水，然后它就会生长，你在阳光下有一个美丽的短暂巅峰，对吧？花瓣绽放了。太华丽了。然后季节变了，花瓣落了，我们平静下来，回到地下。也许那片土地是休耕的，什么也不做，直到环境得到足够的滋养，我们才能再次生长。我认为这是一种非常反文化的思维方式，对吧？我给你举一个完美的例子。因此，我在5月13日推出了我的新书，我在发布会上有一个非常不错的高潮，当时我正在做所有这些活动。就像阳光下的那个巅峰，对吧？花瓣开着。我为这本书工作了将近三年。这真是一个巅峰时刻。然后，你知道，现在是美国这里的夏天。所以我正在平静
down. I'm going back underground because things slow down. Nobody's booking events for the summer. There's a few podcasts here and there, but it's not super busy. But people have been like, are you okay? We notice you're not as productive. We notice that you're like taking more time off. And I'm like, I'm great, right? It's kind of this system that is always asking us to be in perpetual motion that I think is the problem, right? So I think that we really need to flip this idea of more for more sake on its head and really live more into the cycles of ambition. And I think so many of us are afraid to do that. We're afraid that if we take our foot off the gas, that we're going to lose something, like an opportunity or what have you, right? But that's scarcity mindset. And oftentimes in the restful
下来。我回到地下，因为事情慢下来了。夏天没有人预定活动。这里有一些播客，那里有一些播客，但不是很忙。但人们一直在问：“你还好吗？我们注意到你没有那么高效了。我们注意到你休假更多了。”我说：“我很好，对吧？”正是这种总是要求我们处于永恒运动中的系统，我认为这才是问题所在，对吧？所以我觉得我们真的需要把这种“为了更多而更多”的想法彻底颠覆，真正更多地活在野心的周期中。而且我认为我们中的许多人都害怕这样做。我们害怕如果我们松开油门，就会失去什么，比如机会什么的，对吧？但那是稀缺心态。通常在平静的
moment, like this is science. This is not me like being woo-woo. No, yes. Restful moments, right, when our brain has had a moment to relax, to be more parasympathetic, we actually can see more creative options. We can see more opportunities. And so it actually serves us to. allow our ambition to go in cycles? This is, I can confirm, absolutely most certainly true. Anytime we have a scarcity mindset about anything and what people may not know, a scarcity mindset is actually an economics term. And it's now been adopted by psychology, and you would know this. A scarcity mindset is basically what companies try and create so that we value something more. because they understand that the less supply of something there is,
时刻——这可是科学。这不是我在故弄玄虚。不，是的。平静的时刻，对吧，当我们的大脑有了一点放松的时刻，变得更加副交感神经化时，我们实际上可以看到更多有创意的选择。我们可以看到更多机会。所以允许我们的野心按周期发展，实际上是对我们有利的？我可以证实，这绝对是千真万确的。任何时候，当我们对任何事情抱有稀缺心态时，人们可能不知道的是，稀缺心态实际上是一个经济学术语。它现在已被心理学采纳，而你会知道这一点。稀缺心态基本上是公司试图创造的一种心态，这样我们就会赋予某物更高的价值。因为他们明白，某种东西的供应越少，
the more we're going to demand it. And if they can make an item scarce, we immediately think of it as valuable. So if you think that opportunities are scarce, if you think that time is scarce, if you think that your period for success is limited, you're going to hold on as tightly and push yourself further and harder and faster than,
我们的需求就会越大。如果他们能让一件物品变得稀缺，我们就会立刻认为它很有价值。因此，如果你认为机会是稀缺的，如果你认为时间是稀缺的，如果你认为你成功的时间有限，你就会死死抓住不放，把自己推得比
ever imaginable because of that, again, scarcity mindset. However, I think it's so rewarding to see stories of people who became successful at a later age or stories of people like yourself, Amina, who actually know this, I have this incredible career because I have prioritized rest, because I have taken time away. And when we do that, we can actually go deeper into projects. finding this with myself right now where I just said no to something really, really big in my career. Wow. That I really wanted to do.
你能想象的还要远、还要用力、还要快，因为这种——再次强调——稀缺心态。然而，我认为看到那些在晚年获得成功的人的故事，或者像你这样的人的故事，阿米娜，他们实际上知道这一点：“我有这个不可思议的职业生涯，是因为我把休息放在首位，因为我抽出时间离开。”当我们这样做时，我们实际上可以更深入地沉浸在项目中。我最近自己也发现了这一点，我刚刚拒绝了职业生涯中一个非常非常大的机会。哇。我真的很想做。
Thanks. That's actually so nice. Thank you. I really wanted to do this thing. I was like this is, it felt like it was a soul calling. It felt like really important. And I was really excited by it. And then I just was like, I actually just don't.
谢谢。这其实太好了。谢谢。我真的很想做这件事。我当时想，这感觉像是一种内心的召唤。感觉真的很重要。我对此感到非常兴奋。然后我突然觉得，我其实只是不。
I can't do this. I can't equally say to people all the time. I'm so busy. I'm so stressed. I'm so tired. And then continue to add things on. to my plate that will give me even less time to take care of myself. And it was a hard call. But from your perspective, why do you think it's so important to sometimes make those calls?
我做不到。我不能一方面一直对别人说：“我很忙。我很压力。我很累。”然后继续往我的盘子里添加东西，这只会让我有更少的时间照顾自己。这是一个艰难的决定。但从你的角度来看，为什么你认为有时做出这些决定如此重要？
I think you made the most beautiful call, right? So in the book, I talk about purposeful work. And I think purposeful work requires five things. It has to leverage our zone of genius. It has to be values aligned with us. It has to support the impact that we want to have. It has to help us cultivate a sense of contentment and then it has to meet our needs. And what I heard in this opportunity is that it wouldn't meet your needs, right? Your need for a certain amount of time off, right? So it's like that to me is a shiny object. It's something that looks like the dream.
我认为你做出了最美妙的决定，对吧？所以在书中，我谈到了有目的的工作。我认为有目的的工作需要五件事。它必须利用我们的天才区。它必须与我们的价值观相一致。它必须支持我们想要产生的影响。它必须帮助我们培养一种满足感，然后它必须满足我们的需求。而我从这个机会中听到的是，它无法满足你的需求，对吧？你对一定时间休假的需求，对吧？所以对我来说，那是一个闪亮的物体。它看起来像是梦想。
It's adjacent to the dream, but it's not the dream because the dream would allow you to have your needs met, which means you pass the test, right? The actual thing is coming through. You honored yourself, which is a huge thing. Oh, my gosh. I always feel like this is completely a sidebar, but I always feel like I end up interviewing people exactly when I need to hear exactly what they're saying to me. And it's like a selfish thing because I'm sitting here being like, oh, sorry, listeners,
它与梦想相邻，但它不是梦想，因为梦想会允许你的需求得到满足，这意味着你通过了测试，对吧？实际的事情正在发生。你尊重了你自己，这是一件大事。哦，天哪。我总是觉得这完全是一个题外话，但我总是觉得我最终采访别人的时机，恰好就是我需要听到他们对我说的话的时候。这有点自私，因为我坐在这里想，“哦，抱歉，听众们，
I'm going to just ask this expert all the questions I have about my own decisions. But somebody else needs to hear this because it's just so typical, right? It's so typical. It's the shiny object and then not feel like we have enough self-trust or self-worth to hold out for the thing that we really want. So I actually think it's so beautiful that you're sharing this example because you're going to invite others to double down on their self-worth and hold out for the thing that's truly aligned for them. Thank you. I hope you guys feel the same way. This is a question
我接下来要问这位专家所有关于我自己的决定我有过的问题。”但其他人也需要听到这个，因为这太典型了，对吧？这太典型了。这就是那个闪亮的物体，然后感觉我们没有足够的自我信任或自我价值去坚持我们真正想要的东西。所以我其实觉得你分享这个例子太美好了，因为你将邀请其他人加倍关注他们的自我价值，并为真正适合他们的东西坚持到底。谢谢。我希望你们也有同感。这是一个问题，
more for the people in their 20s, which is mostly everyone who listens to this podcast. Why do you think it is hustle culture in particular and not saying no is so seductive, particularly in this, decade? And why do you think that it's important to consciously learn a different way during this time? Yeah, I think it's two things. I think it goes back to what we're talking. talking about with scarcity, right? The idea that we're going to miss an opportunity that's going to set us up for our careers, I have been on my book tour and I was in a room with someone and they asked me a question and they were in their 20s as well. And they were just like, you know, what I've been told is that your 20s is the time to take the risks, right? It's when you can work the hardest,
更多是针对20多岁的人，他们基本上是听这个播客的每个人。为什么你认为“奋斗文化”尤其是“不懂得说不”如此具有诱惑力，特别是在这十年里？为什么你认为在这个时期有意识地学习一种不同的方式很重要？是的，我认为这是两件事。我想这可以追溯到我们一直在谈论的稀缺性，对吧？那种认为我们会错过一个为我们的职业生涯奠定基础的机会的想法，我一直在进行我的新书巡回宣传，我当时在一个房间里，里面有一个人向我提问，他们也是20多岁。他们只是说：“你知道，我被告知的是，20多岁是冒险的时候，对吧？这时候你可以最努力地工作，
you have the least responsibilities potentially outside of work. Like, this is the time to maximize. And I was like, well, to me, that's scarcity mindset. And that's systemically reinforced, right? There's a lot of stuff that gets mirrored back, particularly for women and other historically excluded people. It's like, well, your value is only in your 20s or your value, like, eight. When you're young and beautiful and like fresh. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure. I have clients in their 50s and 60s that it really are facing ageism, right? So that's a real thing to acknowledge. But I think a tremendous amount of pressure gets put on us to achieve the thing in our 20s, because if we don't do it, then we're never going to do it. And I just think that that's BS.
你在工作之外的责任可能最少。看，这是最大化的时候。”我说：“好吧，对我来说，那是稀缺心态。而且那是系统性强化的，对吧？”有很多东西被反射回来，特别是对女性和其他历史上被排斥的人来说。就像，“嗯，你的价值只在你的20多岁，或者你的价值，像——当你年轻、美丽、新鲜时。”是的，是的，是的，是的，当然。我有50多岁和60多岁的客户，他们真的面临着年龄歧视，对吧？所以这是一个需要承认的真实事情。但我认为巨大的压力被施加在我们身上，要求我们在20多岁时取得成就，因为如果我们不这样做，我们就永远不会做了。而我只觉得那是胡说八道。
Like I'm somebody that I was reflecting on this today. I've built my career so sequentially, step by step, choice by choice, right? And I've had a lovely career and I feel really aligned and I feel really squarely in my purpose. And so I think it is that scarcity mindset of like this is the only decade that we can make something happen. And I think that all of these lists, right, like the 30 under 30, the 40 under 40, right, that really glorify and glamorize achieving something in the shortest amount of time, leads me to my second point of urgency culture, right? We live in a culture that thinks that everything is urgent and we have no time to do a thing and we have to do it now. But again, that hurts our bodies, hurts our relationships and upholds oppressive systems. I think that we need to be moving,
就像我是一个今天一直在反思这一点的人。我一步一步、一个选择一个选择地建立我的职业生涯，非常有条理，对吧？我有一个美好的职业生涯，我感到非常一致，我感到非常坚定地处于我的目标之中。所以我觉得这是一种稀缺心态，认为这是我们能够成就一番事业的唯一十年。而且我认为所有这些榜单，对吧，比如“30岁以下30岁精英”、“40岁以下40岁精英”，对吧，它们真正美化和浪漫化了在最短时间内取得成就的行为，这就引导我谈到了我的第二个观点：紧迫感文化，对吧？我们生活在一个认为一切都是紧急的、我们没有时间做某事而必须立刻去做的文化中。但再次强调，这伤害了我们的身体，伤害了我们的关系，并维护了压迫性的系统。我认为我们需要行动，
we need to honor deadlines and dependencies and everything, right? But we need to move at the speed of trust. We need to honor the people and processes it takes to deliver great work. So it's scarcity and its urgency. And this is something that, again, to relate this to my own experiences is what I'm really experiencing right now. I have a podcast called The Psychology of Your 20s. The amount of people who always ask me, are you going to do the psychology of your 30s? What are you going to do when you turn 30?
我们需要遵守截止日期和依赖关系以及所有事情，对吧？但我们需要以信任的速度前进。我们需要尊重交付伟大工作所需的人员和流程。所以它是稀缺性和紧迫性。而这正是——再次将这与我自己的经历联系起来——我目前真正正在经历的。我有一个播客叫《The Psychology of Your 20s》。总是有很多人问我：“你打算做《The Psychology of Your 30s》吗？当你30岁时你打算做什么？
Like, what's the future for you? And I'm like, I don't know. And it is a real sense where it's like, if you accomplish everything that you want in your 20s, what else is there for you? You know what I mean? Like, you've got all the, hopefully all these decades that are coming up that you want to continue to thrive and you want to continue to do things. There's such a pressure to like do everything in your 20s and to have it all together, but it's also like, what if you kind of peek too soon? What if there is, you know, what if there is an identity crisis waiting for you at the other end? Basically, I feel like that's something.
你的未来是什么？”我说：“我不知道。”这是一种真实的感觉，就好像如果你在20多岁时完成了你想要的一切，你还有什么？你知道我的意思吗？就像，你拥有所有，希望你即将迎来的所有十年，你都想继续繁荣，你都想继续做事。有这么大的压力要求你在20多岁时把一切都做好，把一切都搞定，但这也像是在说，如果你过早地达到顶峰怎么办？如果你，你知道，如果在另一端等待你的是一场身份危机怎么办？基本上，我觉得那是正在向我走来的东西，对吧？就像，“哦，是的，我找到了梦想的工作，而且我超级年轻就拥有了梦想的工作。”这并不像人们吹嘘的那样。就像，即使你拥有了你认为你渴望的东西，也总会有一种“更多”的感觉，你永远不会对它感到满意。所以我想说的是，在我们20多岁的时候，我们有一种整体的感觉，我们需要把一切都搞定，我们需要把一切都弄清楚。即使你做到了，即使一切都很顺利，如果你内心深处仍然怀有“野心陷阱”的心态，你将永远不会感到满足。你将永远不会觉得好。
that's coming for me, right? Where it's like, oh, yes, I found the dream job and I have the dream job super early. It's not all that it's like cracked out to be, I think. Like, even if you have what you think you desire, like there's always going to be a sense of more and you're never going to be happy with it. So I guess what I'm trying to say is that in our 20s, we have this whole sense that we need to have it all together and that we need to have it figured out. And even if you do and even And if everything goes well, if you constantly still have the ambition trap mindset, you're never going to feel satisfied. You're never going to feel okay.
这也是你所看到的。野心勃勃的人，无论他们拥有什么，仍然渴望更多，而且从不快乐。是的。所以在书中，我将野心定义为对更多生命的渴望、对成长的愿望、对展现的愿望，对吧？我说它是中立的和自然的，对吧？因为我们确实生活在那个使它对某些人来说是正确的世界里。人们对其他人来说是错误的。有野心的人对更多的生命有这种渴望，对成长有渴望。但我认为，这实际上存在于地球上的每一个生物中。
That's something that you've seen as well. Like ambitious people, no matter what they have, still desire for more and are never, like, happy. Yeah. So in the book, I define ambition as a desire for more life, a wish to grow, a wish to unfold, right? And I say that it's neutral and natural, right? Because we do live in that world that makes it right for some. people and wrong for others. And ambitious people have that desire for more life and a desire to growth. But I, a desire for growth, but I think that's actually in every living thing on the
我不认为有什么有野心的人和没有野心的人。我认为我们实际上都很有野心。我们中的一些人只是因为它的描绘方式而拒绝了这个标签。但地球上的每一个生物都对更多的生命有着渴望，对吧？从我们的植物宝宝到我们的婴儿宝宝。但我认为你所暗指的是陷阱，对吧？因为我认为野心是中立的、自然的。它是为了我们所有人的。它没有什么不好的。这是一件美好的事情。但这不惜一切代价生长的欲望，不惜一切代价获胜的欲望，在这个过程中伤害我们自己的欲望，在这个过程中踩着别人上位的欲望，这才是我们不想做的事情，对吧？
planet. I don't think that there are ambitious people and non-ambitious people. I think we're all actually ambitious. Some of us have just rejected that label because of the way that it's been portrayed. But every living thing on the planet has a desire for more life, right? From our plant babies to our human babies. But I think what you're alluding to is more of the trap, right? Because I think ambition is neutral and natural. It's for all of us. There's nothing wrong with It's a beautiful thing. But this desire to grow no matter the cost, to win no matter the cost, to hurt ourselves in the process, to step over people in the process, that's the thing we don't want to do, right?
有时候确实存在一种倾向。所以在书中，我谈到了两种类型的野心。有一种是痛苦的野心，这正是我刚刚描述的，对吧？不惜一切代价获胜，为了到达那里而伤害自己，以这种不可持续的速度前进。然后是有目的的野心。有目的的野心是当我们的野心与我们的真相相连，并且它来自一个完整的地方。所以这就是我在这项工作中发出的邀请，对吧——离开对我们和他人有害的痛苦片段的旧范式，步入那个更真实的版本。
And sometimes there is a tendency. So in the book, I talk about two types of ambition. There's painful ambition, which is what I just described, right? The winning no matter the cost, the hurting ourselves to get there, moving at this unsustainable pace. And then there's purposeful ambition. Purposeful ambition is when our ambition is connected to our truth and it's coming from a place of wholeness. So that's my invitation in this work, right, is to leave the old paradigm of the painful piece that's harmful to us and others and step into that more truthful version.
在痛苦的野心中，我们总是在移动球门柱。对我们来说，没有什么永远足够。我们征服了一座山，我们就像，“下一座在哪里？”对吧？我们没有停留足够长的时间来欣赏风景。而在有目的的野心中，我们知道生活是一个螺旋式楼梯。我们总是，你知道的，顺着楼梯往上走，顺着楼梯往上走，成长、成为，成为更多的自己，这真是一件非常美妙的事情。
And in painful ambition, we're always moving the goalpost. Nothing is ever enough for us. We achieve one mountain. We're like, where is the next one, right? We don't stop long enough to enjoy the view. And in purposeful ambition, we know that life is a spiral staircase. We're always just, you know, moving up the staircase, moving up the staircase, growing and becoming and becoming more of ourselves, which is a really beautiful thing.
在有目的的野心中，我们更关心满足感。因此，东方传统的满足感在英语中翻译为无条件完整或“知足”的知识。这就是这种想法，无论我们周围发生什么，我们都有这种内部稳定性，告诉我们“我够好了”，对吧？我拥有这种知足的知识。这是一个至关重要的部分，对吧？因为这并不意味着我不想继续成长，这意味着当我和
And in purposeful ambition, we are more concerned with contentment. So contentment from Eastern traditions translates into English as unconditional wholeness or the knowledge of enough. It's this idea that regardless of what's happening around us, we have this internal stability that tells us, I'm enough, right? I have this knowledge of enough. And that is such a crucial piece, right? Because it doesn't mean that I don't want to continue to grow, but it means that while I
成长。我在内心拥有这种无条件的完整，我知道我已经做的一切都足够了，我是谁也足够了。我回答你的问题了吗？哦，天哪，绝对回答了。我想更深入地探讨这个“有目的的野心”概念。有没有，你有一些检查清单吗，一系列问题？我们如何分辨什么时候某事是有目的的野心，而什么时候是痛苦的野心？关键的迹象或区别是什么？所以它们各自有一些特征。痛苦的野心看起来像是以不可持续的速度前进，无论付出什么代价都要获胜的强烈愿望。这里的关键词是“不惜一切代价”，因为获胜本身并没有错。我们都喜欢这样做，对吧？
grow. I have this unconditional wholeness on the inside and I know that everything that I've already done is enough and who I am is enough. Did I answer your question? Oh my God, I absolutely did. And I want to go further into this purposeful ambition concept. Is there, do you have some kind of checklist, a series of questions? How can we tell when something is purposeful ambition versus painful ambition? What are the key signs or distinctions? So they each have a couple of signatures. So painful ambition looks like moving at an unsustainable pace, a strong desire to win no matter the cost. And the key phrase there is no matter the cost because there's nothing wrong with winning. We all love to do it, right?
但这就好像当我们为了达到目标而伤害自己或伤害他人时。这看起来像是在利用我们的身心来达到目标，对吧？就像每周工作80个小时，不睡觉，把压力当作荣誉勋章，所有这些事情。这看起来像是黑白分明的“非此即彼”的思维。然后是有目的的，书里有更多的特征。那些只是其中几个。对。然后有目的的野心是成长型思维，对吧？
But it's like when we'll hurt ourselves or hurt others to get to the goal. It looks like instrumentalizing our minds and bodies to get to the goal, right? So like the 80-hour work weeks, the no-sleeping, the wearing the stress as a badge of honor, all of those things. It looks like black and white either or thinking. And then purposeful, there's more signatures in the book. Those are just a couple. Yeah. And then purposeful ambition is growth mindset thinking, right?
拓展性思维。它与我们的身心保持和谐的关系，对吧？就像我们总是想成长。我们想学一些东西，但我不会为了到达那里而伤害自己。它尊重节奏，以做好工作所需的信任速度前进。它更具协作性，而不是高度个人主义，不需要作为一个个体大放异彩和获胜。我真的很喜欢你所说的话，关于它是协作的和集体的。获胜，就像你说的，这很棒。
Expansive thinking. It is being in a harmonious relationship with our minds and bodies, right? Like we always want to grow. We want to learn some things, but I'm not hurting myself to get there. It is honoring the pace and moving at that speed of trust that it takes to do good work. It is being more collaborative versus hyper individualistic and needing to shine and win as an individual. I really like the thing that you said around it being collaborative and collective. Winning, like you said, it's great.
每个都人类都想这样做。如果你没有人和你一起庆祝，因为你已经几个月没见你的朋友了，因为你没有专注于与同事建立积极的关系，因为你不再给你妈妈打电话。那在顶端可能会相当孤独。会非常孤独。我们知道，许多研究表明，长寿和健康与社区以及拥有一个真正支持性的社区息息相关。实际上，你完全说对了。
Every human wants to do it. If you don't have anyone to celebrate it with because you haven't seen your friends in months because you haven't focused on building positive relationships with your colleagues because you stopped calling your mom. It's kind of going to be pretty lonely at the top. It's going to be so lonely. And we know that so much of the research says that longevity and health are connected to community and having a really supportive community. Actually, you're totally right.
哈佛大学进行过的最长的纵向研究之一，我确信你知道，研究了70多年里的大量参与者。他们得出的结论是，健康和长寿的关键因素是某人与他人拥有的积极和健康关系的数量。我们马上回来进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我想更多地谈谈竞争如何伤害我们、野心惩罚、自我破坏，以及如何真正努力培养自己的自我意识，以便以更健康的方式对待野心。保持收听。《2%》。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
One of the longest longitudinal studies ever done at Harvard University, which I'm sure you know, looked at a number of participants for like 70 plus years. And they were like the key factor in health and longevity was the number of positive and healthy relationships that someone. has with others. We are going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to talk more about how competition harms us, the ambition penalties, self-sabotage, and how to truly work on your own sense of self in order to approach ambition in a more healthy way. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和培养抗挫力背后的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships,
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟杀死一个小动物有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
包括最近一集马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备谈论可卡因，但为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at it”。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖姆斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的经验。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我在心理健康领域的经验以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利和失败。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我在说话。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross。因为你发现在人间的时候做一个好人是很重要的。你是一个因为害怕才当好人的人吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
我是科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），欢迎和我一起，在我的新播客《艰难之路》（Learn the Hardway）中，就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeart Radio 应用程序。搜索《艰难之路》（Learn the Hardway）并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在这个特定测试中作假了两次，对吧？我伪造过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格（Greg），一个女同性恋，还有迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱之陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉（Laura），斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》（Love Trapped）播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》（The Girlfriends）的这个新季度里……天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都跟同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以他们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we are back talking about the ambition trap. I want to focus in on one part of. of this in particular, which is how competition harms us. We kind of talked about it in relation to obviously harming our personal relationships and perhaps the relationship with our colleagues or our friends. Can you go deeper into talking about how that specifically applies to those of us
收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。好的，我们回来聊聊野心陷阱。我想特别关注其中的一部分，那就是竞争如何伤害我们。我们之前讨论过它显然会损害我们的个人关系，以及可能与同事或朋友的关系。你能更深入地谈谈这具体如何适用于我们这些人
in our 20s, maybe? Yes, I think competition again goes back to scarcity mindset. I feel like that's the theme of today. Yeah, we're just like scarcity mindset guys, the one word you need to know. Exactly. And the thing about scarcity mindset, right, is like it's a systemic and economic problem, but it has those two pieces. It has the mindset piece and the fact that it's systematically reinforced, right? So oftentimes what we see in the workplace is like, oh, there's space for only one woman or one person in their 20s or, you know, one person of color. And we're like, oh, my God, well, I've got to beat out everybody that looks like me to get this thing, right? It causes infighting in those groups. And so I think that, yes, we absolutely need to look at our own mindset. I'm like, where do I, feel like I have to fight out this other person to win, right? There's stuff on our side of the street
大概20多岁的时候吗？是的，我认为竞争再次归结为稀缺心态。我觉得这就是今天的主题。是的，我们就像是稀缺心态的人，你需要知道的一个词。完全正确。关于稀缺心态的事情，对吧，就像它是一个系统性和经济性的问题，但它有这两个部分。它有心态部分，以及它在系统上得到强化的事实，对吧？所以很多时候我们在职场中看到的是，哦，这里只容纳一个女性，或者一个20多岁的人，或者，你知道的，一个有色人种。然后我们会想，哦，天哪，好吧，我必须打败所有长得像我的人才能得到这个东西，对吧？它会导致这些群体内部的内斗。所以我认为，是的，我们绝对需要审视自己的心态。我想，我在哪里觉得自己必须与另一个人争夺才能赢，对吧？我们这边也有一些问题
there. But also there's stuff that needs to shift inside of organizations so that it doesn't give us that impulse, right? I always say to my clients too, when we're captivated by purpose, we can't be consumed by competition. And I think this is so important, especially for work like you, like yours and mine, right? It's so easy to look on social media and be like, oh, well, this person's doing this and I should be doing this, right? But when we're so captivated and devoted, to our purpose. We're not looking in the other lane. We're like, I see what I'm here to do. And it is so beautiful and I'm so devoted to that thing. And that's what gets me out of bed every day. I'm actually getting emotional saying this. It's like you don't have time or care to look around because you're so
但同时，组织内部也需要发生转变，这样它才不会给我们那种冲动，对吧？我也总是对我的客户说，当我们被目标迷住时，我们就不会被竞争吞噬。我认为这非常重要，特别是对于像你这样、像你我这样的工作来说，对吧？在社交媒体上很容易看到并觉得，哦，这个人正在做这个，我也应该这样做，对吧？但当我们如此着迷并投身于我们的目标时。我们不会去看另一条赛道。我们会觉得，我知道我来这里是为了做什么。它是如此美丽，我如此投入于那件事。这就是每天让我起床的动力。说实话，我现在都有点情绪激动了。这就像你没有时间或心思去环顾四周，因为你被你的贡献以一种美妙的方式完全吞噬了。
consumed with your contribution in a beautiful way. And you know what? I've experienced that recently, actually, now that you've said it, where when I first was, you know, growing the psychology of your 20s and not even intentionally people were just finding it. Which is a beautiful thing. It was great. Yeah, I was so lucky, but I was so insecure because I didn't expect it. I never had this experience before. And I was like, I have to be doing better.
你知道吗？其实我最近也体验过这一点，既然你已经这么说了，当我最初在，你知道的，发展《20s的心理学》（the psychology of your 20s）时，甚至都不是刻意的，人们只是发现了它。这是一件美好的事情。这太棒了。是的，我很幸运，但我又是如此不安全，因为我没有预料到这一点。我以前从来没有过这种经历。当时我想，我必须做得更好。
I have to be making the most original and the best kind of episodes. I have to be putting everything into this. And as it is with anything that's entertainment, you know, there are charts and there are ratings and there are all these things. And I really wish that wasn't part of this medium and I wish that it was just more organic, but it is. And it would really kind of took some of the joy out of it for me was competition. Now I'm in this phase and in this place where I'm just so delighted by what I'm doing. And I felt it really in the last maybe six months where I don't really check download numbers. I don't really check what I don't
我必须制作出最具原创性和最好的剧集。我必须把所有东西都投入到这里面。就像任何娱乐事业一样，你知道，有排行榜，有收视率，还有所有这些东西。我真的希望这不是这个媒介的一部分，我希望它更自然一些，但事实并非如此。这确实夺去了我的一些乐趣，那就是竞争。现在我处于这个阶段和位置，我只是对我在做的事情感到非常高兴。在过去的六个月里，我真的感受到了这一点，我不再怎么查看下载量了。我真的不怎么检查什么，我真的不怎么关注。我想这是因为我不知何故变得更有目标感和意图性，不再需要证明我有能力做到这一点，我有能力把这件事做好。现在我终于可以享受它了。所以我喜欢你谈论这个。还有就是快乐的作用。你认为快乐对野心又有什么作用呢？是的。我只想为刚才你说的最后那点做个总结，因为我觉得它太美妙、太重要了，我们确实生活在一个由指标支撑的世界里，对吧？就像对我来说一样。我的书销量很重要，对吧？是的。
really pay attention. And I think it's because I've somehow become a lot more purposeful and intentional in that there is no longer I need to prove that I'm capable of doing this and I'm capable of being good at this. Now I can just enjoy it. So I like that I like that you talked about that. And also like the role of joy. What do you think the role of joy is an ambition as well? Yeah. And I just want to just put a bow on that last thing that you said because I think it's so beautiful and important because we do live in a world that is upheld by metrics, right? It's like same for me. It's like my book sales matter, right? Yeah.
但我从你那里听到并对我很重要的是，这并不是出发点，对吧？那不是驱动我们的动力。驱动我们的动力是投身于了不起的工作。然后往往这的副产品就是数字，对吧？但就像当我们着手去冲榜、去达成目标时，有太多的控制欲。我认为这绝对会掩盖快乐。我想回答你关于快乐的问题，但如果可以的话，这里有一个承上启下的话题。我需要它。我需要它。告诉我这个承上启下的话题。这就是我。就像我刚才谈到的控制欲一样，对吧？这对我来说说明了核心创伤。所以在书中，当我谈到痛苦的野心时，痛苦的野心是由核心创伤驱动的。所以在书中，我借鉴了丽丝·布尔博（Lees Borbeau）的工作，
But what I'm hearing from you and what's important for me is that's not the come from, right? That's not the driver for us. The driver for us is being devoted to amazing work. And then oftentimes the byproduct of that is the numbers, right? But it's like when we set out to like hit the chart and hit the goal and like it's so much control. And that I think eclipses joy for short. And I want to answer your joy question, but there's a segue here if I can. I need it. I need it. Tell me the segue. Here it's me. So like what I was just talking about with control, right? What that says to me is core wound. So in the book, when I talk about painful ambition, painful ambition is driven by core wounds. So in the book, I leverage the work of Lees Borbeau,
她是一位加拿大心理学家，她谈到有五种核心创伤：拒绝、遗弃、羞辱、背叛和不公正。作为每一种创伤的结果，我们戴上了相应的人格面具。如果你有拒绝的创伤，你戴的面具就是逃避。如果你有背叛的创伤，你戴的面具就是控制。那也是我的面具之一。所以有时我们可以开始看到我们的创伤或面具是如何妨碍我们在工作背景下真正感受到快乐和满足的。所以你给出的那个例子非常完美，是核心创伤驱动野心的典型例子。那就是痛苦的野心。而你现在所在的地方就像是美丽、有目的的野心。就像是摘下了面具。
who's a Canadian psychologist, and she talks about how there's five core wounds, rejection, abandonment, humiliation, betrayal, and injustice. And as a result of each of the wounds, we were a corresponding mask. So if you have a rejection wound, the mask you wear is avoidance. If you have a betrayal wound, the mask you wear is control. That's one of mine. And so sometimes we can start to see where our wound or mask is getting in the way of actually feeling joy and contentment in the context of our work. So that example you gave is so perfect and classic of core wound driving the ambition. And that's painful ambition. And where you are now is like beautiful, purposeful ambition. like releasing the mask.
我想我必须这样做的方式是，显然你也会这么做。你需要做大量的自我心理工作。你还得重新回到这样的状态：在这里我有一个选择。我可以拥有所有的成功和所有美好的事物。我可以每天为此痛恨自己，觉得我的生活在我周围燃烧。然后我 constamment 处于一种紧迫的状态和一种内心的追求状态。或者我可以拥有这一切，只是接受有时我只是很幸运。有时这些事情，人们确实会对你产生共鸣。有时你已经完成了所有的
And I think the way I had to do that was obviously you would have done this as well. Like you have to do a lot of self work. You also just have to get back to being like, I have a choice here. I can have all the success and all the good things. And I can hate myself for it every single day and feel like my life is burning around me. And then I am constantly in a state of urgency and an inner state. state of pursuit. Or I can have all of this and just accept that sometimes I am just lucky. And sometimes this stuff, people do just really resonate with you. And sometimes you've done all
艰苦的工作，并且那种投资已经得到了回报。你不需要继续证明自己。我相信你也会发现这一点。野心是如何归结为证明自己的需求的？你发现这两者之间有什么联系吗？是的。那是典型的痛苦的野心，对吧，我们在证明自己。这可以追溯到核心创伤。所以，你知道，我的核心创伤之一是拒绝，我戴的面具是逃避，对吧？所以因为我在童年时期感到被拒绝，作为成年人，我会避免把我的帽子扔进圈子里，因为我太担心自己会再次被拒绝。正因为我有这种拒绝的创伤，并且没有感受到这种被接受的感觉，我感到了反复证明自己的冲动。它看起来非常相似
the hard work and that, like that investment has paid off. You don't have to continue to prove yourself. I'm sure you find this as well. Like how does ambition come down to the need to prove ourselves? Have you found a link between those two things as well? Yes. That's classic. painful ambition, right, proving ourselves. And it goes back to the core wounds. So, you know, one of my poor wounds is rejection and the mask I wear is avoidance, right? So because I felt rejected as a child, I will avoid as an adult throwing my hat in the ring because I'm so worried that I'll be rejected again. And because I have this rejection wound and don't feel this sense of acceptance, I feel this impulse to prove myself over and over again. And it looks very similar
对于所有其他核心创伤也是如此。所以我们生来就是有价值的，对吧？我们天生就是有价值的。有人会看着一个刚出生的婴儿说，但是没有价值，对吧？不，你看着一个婴儿，你会想，哦，天哪，它是如此完美。但是所有这些东西都从我们的家庭系统、文化等叠加到我们身上。我们把它当成我们自己的，我们认为我们不够好，我们必须证明我们是有价值的。你生来就是有价值的。这就是我们每个人都需要回归的信息。当我们意识到我们对成长的渴望不是来自那种证明自己的地方，而是来自这实际上只是我真相的自然展现。
for all the other core wounds as well. And so we are all born, worthy, right? We were born innately worthy. Would anybody look at a brand new baby and be like, but not worthy, right? No, you look at a baby and you're like, oh my God, it's so perfect. But all this stuff gets layered onto us from our family systems, from culture, et cetera. We adopted as our own and we think that we're not enough and that we have to prove that we are valuable. You're born valuable. And that's the message that each of us needs to come home to. And when we realize that our desire for growth isn't coming from that place to prove ourselves, it's coming from this is actually just a natural unfolding of my truth.
我真的很喜欢你说的。就像，无论你是否成功，你都是完全有价值的。就像，无论你是选择追求伟大宏伟的事物，还是选择过一种非常精彩、缓慢而简单的生活。是的。没有哪一种生活方式比另一种更有价值。只要你没有伤害别人或伤害自己，只要你拥有幸福、善良和快乐，
And I really like that you said that. Like, you are completely worthy, whether you are successful or not. Like, whether you choose to pursue big, great grand things, or you choose to just live a really amazing and slow and simple life. Yes. There is not one life path that is more valuable than another. as long as you are not hurting other people or hurting yourself, as long as you have happiness and kindness and joy,
你可以成为《纽约时报》畅销书作家，你可以是一个只拥有一个灿烂的花园并与三个人交谈的人，这两种生活都具有内在的价值。我认为这也归结为我们社会中存在的这种奇怪的等级制度，即如果你有钱，如果你有成功，如果你是一个公众人物，拥有一个面向公众的人设，那么，你一定比其他任何人都要快乐。
you could be like at New York Times bestseller, you could be someone who just has a brilliant garden and talks to three people and both of those lives are like inherently valuable. I think it also comes down to this weird hierarchy we have in our society that like if you have money and if you have success and if you have a public figure, a public facing like kind of persona, well, you must be happier than anyone else.
如果你更快乐，那么显然，你的生活就更好。但如果其他人认为你更成功、更快乐，那么这就会为这一点增添更多色彩。你遇到的一些最成功的人实际上内心深处并不快乐。哦，天哪。大多数人。是的。大多数人。是的。就像世界上一些最富有的人一样，他们没有可以信任的人。就像他们不喜欢自己一样。公众不喜欢他们。
And if you are happier, then obviously, like, your life is better. But if other people perceive you as being more successful and happier, then that adds to that even more. Some of the most successful people you meet are actually deeply unhappy. Oh my gosh. Most people. Yeah. Most people. Yeah. And like some of the richest people in the world, it's like they don't have anyone they can trust. like they don't like themselves. The public doesn't like them.
他们看起来不像很好的人。那么，我们认为这就是生活秘诀的到底是什么呢？是的。我一直在想这个问题。我认为这根本不是一个奇怪的哲学问题。我们在一个资本主义体系中运作，对吧？资本主义说，钱越多越好，对吧？但这正是野心陷阱的本质，因为我们知道我们可以拥有所有的钱，
They don't seem like very good people. So what is it about this that we think is like the secret to life? Yes. I think about this all the time. I don't think it's a weird philosophical question at all. We operate in a capitalist system, right? And capitalism says the more money, the better, right? But that's the essence of the ambition trap because we know that we can get all of the money,
所有的赞誉，所有的战车，所有的奖杯，所有的粉丝。如果你不在内心做功课，你仍然会很痛苦，对吧？因为幸福并不存在于我们之外。满足感并不存在于我们之外。满足感在内心。甚至在书中，我也确实非常小心，不要过度使用“幸福”这个词，因为我认为即使那样也会变得有点麻烦，因为幸福是一种情绪，因此是短暂的。我们不可能一直快乐。实际上，地球上最健康的人是那些为情绪多样性（即所有情绪来来去去）腾出空间的人。所以即使是这个，就像
all of the accolades, like all of the chariots, like all of the trouble. trophies, all of the followers. And if you don't do the work on the inside, you are still going to be miserable, right? Because the happiness doesn't live outside of us. The contentment doesn't live outside of us. The contentment's on the inside. And even in the book, I actually was really careful not to overuse the language of happiness because even that I think can become a little troubling because happiness is an emotion and is therefore transient. We're not supposed to be happy all the time. We're actually the healthiest people on the planet are the ones that make space for emo diversity, which is all emotions coming and going. And so even this, like, I
执着于幸福的想法，并将其作为北极星，是有点麻烦的，因为我们应该感受一切。我们应该感受悲伤、悲痛、幸福、快乐、失望，所有这些，不是死死抓住不放，而是让它们以本应有的方式来去自如，这就是为什么我提倡满足感。所以我不认为这些人快乐，我也不认为他们感到满足，因为我认为他们是在向外寻求东西，而真正的工作在内心。不，绝对的。我可以这么说，作为一个人，我已经落入这个陷阱很多很多次了。该死。
idea of clinging to happiness, and that's the North Star, is slightly troubling because we're supposed to feel everything. We're supposed to feel sadness, grief, happiness, joy, disappointment, all of it, not grip onto it, but let it come and go in the way that it's supposed to, which is why I'm an advocate for contentment. And so I don't think any of these people are happy, nor do I think that they're contented because I think that they're seeking the thing outside of themselves when the work is on the inside. No, absolutely. And I can say, as someone, I've fallen into that many, many a time. Damn.
我读过这本书。不，真的，完全如此。这也是一种感觉，就像我前几天对某人说的那样。我在社交媒体上发布最多、把我的生活描绘得最不可思议的时期，也往往是我最不满足的时期，不是最不快乐，也不是非常快乐，而是最不满足。因为我觉得外部的某种验证会填补某种空虚，或者会填补某种。让我们感到有价值。
I read the book. No, literally, exactly. It's also this sense of like, I was saying this to someone the other day as well. The times as well that I've been posting on social media the most that I've portrayed my life as being the most incredible have also been the times that I've been the least content, not the least happy, also not very happy, but the least content. Because I felt like the external validation would feel some kind of whole or would feel some kind of. Make us feel valuable.
我想这就是这一切的归宿，对吧？我们与野心的关系是不健康的，因为我们认为野心将带来的成功或痛苦的野心将填补我们生活中没有任何其他东西可以填补的空白。它将满足某种永远无法通过其他任何东西满足的需求。金钱、认可、成功。如果你继续相信这一点，就像你说的，你讲述了自己因精疲力竭而生病的故事。你自我破坏。你没有良好的人际关系。
And I think this is what this is all coming back to, right? We have an unhealthy relationship with ambition because we think that the success that ambition will bring or painful ambition will bring is going to fill a whole in our life that nothing else can fill. And it's going to feel some kind of need that can never be fulfilled by anything other than. money, recognition, success. And if you continue to believe that, like you said, you spoke of your story of becoming ill from burnout. You self-sabotage. You don't have good relationships.
所以我的问题是，我们如何开始重新定义这一点？我们如何开始将自己视为有价值的，并将我们的野心视为可持续的？而不会伤害我们。是的，我认为这是价值百万美元的问题。我真的相信它始于对核心创伤的功课。所以 literalmente 在引言和第一章中，我直接切入了这个主题，因为我想，我不想浪费任何时间。
So my question for you is, how do we begin to redefine this? How do we begin to see ourselves as valuable and see our ambition as sustainable? without it hurting us. Yeah, I think this is the million dollar question. And I really believe it starts with the work on the core wounds. So literally in the introduction and in chapter one, I get straight into this because I'm like, I don't want to waste any time.
这就是我们需要关注的地方。是的，拜托。所以我认为我们需要真正了解哪些创伤是我们的，它们是如何表现在我们与野心、成功和工作的关系中的。甚至还有友谊，它一直表现在人际关系中。我经常听到这个问题。所以它无处不在。如果我们不针对核心创伤做那些功课，我们将不断地在自身之外寻找东西，因为我们在内心感到自己不值得。所以我们需要尽我们所能为那个创伤带来尽可能多的抚慰。否则，我们就会陷入对自身之外事物的永恒追逐中。所以我觉得这是最基础的功课之一。而且，你知道，这很有趣，因为我不知道创伤是否真的能“完全治愈”。对。我想它总是像，你知道的，结一点痂，留一点疤，就像在变好一样，对吧？在它周围建立胶原蛋白。
Like this is where we need to focus. Yes, please. And so I think that we need to really understand which wounds are ours and how they're showing up in our relationship to ambition and success and work. And even friendships, like it shows up in relationships all the time. I get this question so much. So it's everywhere. And if we don't do that work on the core wounds, we are going to be constantly seeking the thing outside of ourselves because we don't feel worthy on the inside. So we need to bring as much of a salve to that wound as we possibly can. Otherwise, we're in a perpetual chase outside of ourselves. So that I think is some of the most fundamental work. And, you know, it's interesting because I don't know that the wound is ever like fully healed. Right. I think it's always like, you know, getting a little scab, a little scar, like getting better, right? Building the collagen around it.
我总是用隐喻，但我认为我们职业生涯的每一个新高度和我们的成长，我们都有不同的处理方式，对吧？就像你从事一个非常公开的职业。我从事一个公开的职业。因为我已经对那些核心创伤做了功课，因为我已经对我的神经系统进行了功课，你知道的，有很多积极的方面，但它也伴随着一些消极的方面。但我现在有能力承受它了，它不会影响我的价值，因为我已经做了那个功课，对吧？我觉得从事像我或你这样的职业会很难，如果我们把价值外包出去，因为
I'm always metaphor, but I think every next level of our careers and our becoming, we have a different way of dealing with it, right? It's like you're in a very public career. I'm in a public career. And because I've done work on those core wounds, because I've worked on my nervous system, you know, there's a lot of positivity, but there's also some negativity that comes with it. But I'm equipped to hold it now and it doesn't impact my value because I've done that work, right? It's like I think it'd be so hard to be in a career like mine or yours if we were outsourcing our value because
每一个评论都是，哦，太糟糕了。是的。是的。真的，我前几天还在和另一个朋友谈论这件事。这不仅发生在这个行业，在任何行业都发生过，但是，对于她来说，我谈到了她会如何收到仇恨评论。这简直毁了她的生活。
every comment are, oh, it's the worst. Yeah. Yeah. Literally, I was talking to another friend of mine about this the other day. And it happens not just in this industry in any industry, but like, for her, I was talking about how like she would get hate comments. And it just ruins her life.
就像她的，她的一天被毁了。她什么也做不了。而那个人根本没想过这件事。这就跟你在办公室工作，然后有一个职场霸凌者一样。他们不在乎，他们不在乎。这将会彻底摧毁你。我认为，这又是这件事，你不能把你的价值悬挂在一段关系上，悬挂在别人的看法上，悬挂在物质成功上。所有这些东西都是完全
Like her, her day is ruined. She cannot do anything else. And that person hasn't thought about it at all. It's the same with like you're in an office job and like there's a workplace bully. They don't, they don't care. And it's going to completely. completely destroy you. I think that it's, again, this thing, you cannot hinge your value on a relationship, on someone else's perception, on material success. All of those things are completely
脆弱的。当你有一种内在的感觉：我是有价值的，我做得很棒，我有能力，我相信自己，你就像是不可动摇的。即使是刻薄和残酷的话，别人说的任何话也永远不会伤害你。是的，完全正确。我认为这非常重要。我听说过“受伤的人伤害别人”，所以他们来自核心创伤，看到这一点非常重要，如果你能在那时仍然感到完整，对吧？也许我们在其中甚至能有所学，对吧？我认为这也是一件美好的事。但如果它没有把我们击垮，那就是魔咒所在。这也阻止了创伤变得具有传染性，就像那个试图打倒你的人或不管是什么一样，正如你所说，受伤的人伤害别人，某人伤害了他们，如果你把它揽过来，让它伤害了你
fallible. When you have an internal sense of, I am worthy and I do great things and I am capable and I trust myself, you are like unshakable. Like nothing anyone says is ever going to harm you, even if it's nasty and cruel. Yeah, exactly. I think that's so important. I heard people hurt people right so they're coming from a poor wound and that's so important to see and if you can then still feel whole in that right and maybe there's even a learning for us in it right i think that's always a beautiful thing too but if it doesn't take us down like there's the magic and also it stops that wound from becoming contagious like that person who has tried to bring you down or whatever it is like hurt people hurt people as you said someone has hurt them you if you take it on and you let that injure you
你将继续对别人做同样的事。这就是为什么有时候我们最大的黑粉往往是对自己最不自信的人。是的。因为没有可能。不，不，请继续。关于它具有传染性的那部分是如此真实，对吧？如果我们继续生活在我们的创伤中，那么我们就是在邀请其他人也这样做。所以为我们自己的创伤做功课是一项巨大的服务。
you will continue to do that to someone else. It's why sometimes like our biggest haters are the ones that are most insecure about themselves. Yeah. Because there's no way. No, no, go ahead. The part about it being contagious is so true, right? If we continue to live in our wounds, then we're just inviting others to do the same. And like, so then it's such an act of service for us to do the work on ours.
说得太美妙了。特别是像你之前谈到的那样，关于野心也是关于社区和合作的。就像，这一切都在汇聚，修复你的核心创伤。这是你能给出的最好的礼物，不仅是对你的孩子或你的家庭成员，而且是对任何与你接触的人，你让自己成为野心可以是什么样子以及与自我的健康关系可以是什么样子的一的榜样，以至于其他人也加入进来，并且觉得，我超级有能力做到这一点。这就是魔幻所在。真的，人们会问，好吧，我们如何用这个来改变世界？
It's so beautifully said. And especially like what you were talking about before in terms of like ambition is also about community and also about collaboration. It's like, it's all coming together, fixing your poor wounds. Like that is the greatest gift you can give, not just to like your children or to your family members, but to anyone who comes into contact with you, you allow yourself to be this example of what ambition can look like and what a healthy relationship with self can look like such that other people jump on the bandwagon and like, I'm super capable of doing that as well. That's where the magic is. Literally, that's what people are like, well, how do we
对吧？我说，好吧，它始于我们，因为在我们做那项功课的那一刻，我们的表现就不同了。我们与周围的每个人都在共舞，对吧？所以如果我向左走而不是向右走，现在他们就在迁就我，他们也不同了。然后世界就会产生这种美丽的涟漪效应。所以它始于我们，但它可以很容易地从那里成长。哦，绝对百分之百。就像人们没有意识到，你知道的，六度分隔的理念，这个世界上的每个人最多都被六度隔开。这太疯狂了。
change the world with this? Right? I'm like, well, it starts with us because the minute that we do that work, we show up differently. And we're in a dance with everybody around us, right? So if I go left instead of going right, now they're accommodating me and they're different too. And then there's this beautiful ripple effect out in the world. And so it starts with us, but it can very easily grow from there. Oh, absolutely 100%. Like people don't realize, you know, the idea of obviously like six degrees of separation, like every single person in this in this world is separated by maximum six degrees. It's wild.
当你真正开始这样做时，我和我的朋友有时会这样做，我们会想，这个随机的人和这个随机的国家。你会发现，它总是六度。所以想象一下，这种积极性能以多快的速度传播。如果我们真的开始去生活，关于野心的这种新愿景能以多快的速度传播。不过，我有一个后续问题，我确信这也是许多人问自己的问题，我们如何在不觉得自己落后的情况下故意放慢脚步，
Like when you really start doing it, me and my friends do this sometimes we're like, this random person and this random country. And it's like you can, it's always six degrees. So imagine how quick that positivity can spread. And imagine how quick that new vision of ambition can spread if we just really start to live it. I do have a follow-up question, though, and I'm sure it's one that a lot of people are asking themselves, how can we deliberately slow down without feeling like we're falling behind,
特别是在我们20多岁的时候？因为我觉得这是这个十年的年轻人特别纠结的事情。是的，这真是个好问题。我认为有两件事。首先，是在我们的天才区工作。所以在书中，我谈到了，所以天才区是盖伊·亨德里克斯（Gay Hendricks）在他的书《大跃进》（The Big Leap）中创造的一个术语。在书中，我谈到我们在三个区域运作。所以我们有我们的天才区或卓越区，我们的优秀区，以及我们的平均水平空间。
especially in our 20s? Because I feel like this is something that people in this decade struggle with, especially. Yes, this is such a good one. And so I think there's two things. First, it is working in our zone of genius. So in the book, I talk about how, so zone of genius is a term that was coined by Gay Hendricks in his book, The Big Leap. And in the book, I talk about how we operate in three zones. So we have our genius or our exceptional zone, our excellent zone in our zone, the space that we're average at.
所以当我们知道我们的天才区是什么，或者我们非凡的特质是什么时，我们必须消耗少得多的精力和时间，因为那是我们的魔力。它有点天生。你不需要推或强迫，对吧？我可以看到这是你天才的一部分，你现在正在做的事情。所以你可以出现在这件事情中，除非，你不需要每天花八小时在这上面，对吧？它经过了如此精细的调整和强效，以至于你不需要整天、每天都在做它。所以我认为从我们的优秀区或区域的转变，这是我们大多数人开始职业生涯的地方，因为我们在磨练。如果你甚至可以每天花10分钟在你的天才区，然后随着时间的推移建立它，你就不必担心放慢速度，因为你在天才区中的贡献将是如此强大。
And so when we know what our zone of genius is or what our exceptional traits are, we have to use so much less energy and time because it's our magic. It's just kind of innate. You don't have to push or force, right? I can see that this is part of your genius, what you're doing right now. And so you can show up in this thing unless, like you don't need to spend eight hours a day in this, right? It's like it's so fine-tuned and potent that you don't need to spend all day, every day doing it. So I think that shift from our excellent zone or our zone, which is where most of us start our careers because we're kind of honing. And if you can spend even just starting by 10 minutes a day in your zone of genius and then building that over time, you don't have to worry about slowing down because the contribution over in your genius is going to be so potent.
它弥补了一切。另一个部分是让你的神经系统在做更少的事情时感到安全，因为我们生活在一个移动如此之快的世界里，知识变化如此之快。每个人都在以百万英里每小时的速度前进。所以对于我们大多数人的神经系统来说，放慢速度感觉是不安全的。就像我目前处于这个季节，正如我之前提到的，节奏稍微慢一点。现在是夏天。正因为我刚刚经历了一个非常忙碌的季节，我注意到我的神经系统起初在想，这安全吗？我们习惯了以百万英里每小时的速度奔跑，尤其是在过去的一年里。这可以吗？我不得不真正做功课，让我的身体在这个较慢的节奏下感到安全。但提醒我自己，对吧，我不必做所有事情。我只需要做我最擅长、最强大的那件事。我认为这对任何人都是真的，无论他们处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，但在20岁时尤其如此。是的。特别是当你正在试验的时候，对吧？可以这样想：我其实并不擅长这个，我不需要通过证明自己能成为最好来证明什么。就像我上大学学经济学时一样，我想，我永远不会成为这个学科的顶尖学生。这根本不会发生。是的。我也学过经济学，也知道自己不会成为该主题的顶尖学生。我当时想，好吧，我们要成为该主题的顶尖学生。我说，好吧，我们要做的。拿个B就能混过去。我们都很好。是的，是的。当我学到微观经济学2时，我就出局了。我想，微观经济学2是我觉得这不是我的未来的时候。就像，这不是我将要成为的人。
It makes up for everything. And then the other piece is letting your nervous system feel safe doing less because we like live in a world that is moving so fast and knowledge changes so quickly. everybody's moving at a million miles a minute. And so it feels unsafe for most of our nervous systems to go slow. Like I'm in this season right now, like I mentioned before, where it's a little slower. It's the summer. And just because I had came off a season that was so busy, I noticed that my nervous system at first was like, is this safe? We're used to running a million miles a minute, especially for the last year. Is it okay? And I had to really do the work to let my body feel safe at this slower pace. But reminding myself, right, of like, I don't need to do everything. I need to do the thing that I am best and most potent at. And I think that's true for anybody, whatever stage of their career, but especially in our 20s. Yeah. And especially as you're experimenting, right? It's okay to be like, I'm actually not that good at this and I don't have anything to prove by proving that I can be the best. Like, I had this when I was in uni and I was studying economics and I was like, I'm never going to be a top student in the subject. It's just not going to happen. Yeah. I also studied economics and also knew that I was not going to be a top student in the topic. I was like, well, we're going to be a top student in the topic. I was like, well, we're going to be. I'll buy with a B. We're all right. Yeah, yeah. That's when I got to micro two, I was out. I was like, microeconomics two is where I was like, this is not my future. Like, this is not who I'm going to be.
哦，天哪。我也是。我们在微观经济学2中的班级平均分是100分中的36分。那是班级平均分。就像，我们都挂科了。哦，天哪。不。你看，我是COVID期间学的，我想他们对我们更友善一些，因为就像我一样，我的最后一年是COVID的第一年。然后我还上了宏观经济学2。事情实在太多了。但是，你知道的，我记得当时想，哦，天哪，我总是把那么多的精力投入到我的成绩中。我总是把这么多东西和我的产出挂钩。如果我不擅长这个，雇主就不会想雇佣我做这个，做那个。我必须在每件事上都表现得很惊艳。
Oh my God. Same. Our class average in microeconomics two was a 36 out of 100. That was a class average. Like, we were all failing. Oh my God. No. See, I did it during COVID and I think that they were nicer to us because like I was, it was like my last year was the first year of COVID. And then I also did like macro two. It was just a lot. But, you know, I remember being like, oh, my God, I've always put so much in my grades. And I've always tied so much to like my output. And if I'm not good at this, like an employer isn't going to want to hire me for this, for this. I have to be amazing at everything.
否则我就是一个全面发展的人，等等等等。然后我想，等一下。我可以把更多精力集中在这些心理学学科上，我的平均绩点也会保持不变，因为我在做。这只是一个非常基础的时刻，但就是这样一个时刻，让我觉得，我不会放弃，但我会花更多时间在我的天才区，花更多时间在我擅长的事情上。因为我们都有天赋。我们都有一些东西，可能有多件事情，这将是轻而易举的，对我们来说更容易变得伟大。
Otherwise, I'm not a well-rounded individual. And I blah, blah, blah, blah. And then I was like, wait a second. Like, I can focus more on these psychology subjects and my grade point average will say the same because I'm doing. I was just like this such a basic moment, but just this moment of being like, I'm not going to give up, but I'm just going to spend more time in my zone of genius and spend more time on the thing that I'm like good at. Because we all do have natural talents. We all have something that we, probably multiple things that we are going to be, it's going to be easy for us, easier for us to be great at.
所以也许20多岁的一部分不仅是弄清楚你喜欢什么，也是弄清楚对你来说那个东西是什么。而且通常乐趣也会随之而来，对吧？因为如果你天生擅长某事，就更容易进入心流状态。更容易感到有目标感。所以老实说，这是极其强大的，对吧？我想对你说的唯一一件事是，因为我觉得我的20多岁是一个勾选所有我不擅长的事情以找到我擅长的事情的过程。我认为有时这个过程会让人感到黏稠和不舒服。但这才是旅程，对吧？就像只是觉得，哦，不是那件事，不是那件事。哦，是这件事情，对吧？所以如果你正处于这个过程中，觉得你已经做完了所有你不擅长的事情。
And so maybe part of like being in your 20s is not just finding out what you enjoy, but also finding out what that is for you. And also normally the enjoyment comes with it, right? Because if you're naturally good at something, it's easier to get into a flow state. It's easier to feel like purposeful. So honestly, it's incredibly powerful, right? And the one thing I want to say to you is because I feel like my 20s was a process of checking off everything that I was not good at to get to what I was good at. And I think sometimes that process can feel like sticky and uncomfortable. But that's the journey, right? Of like just being like, oh, not that thing, not that thing. Oh, this thing, right? So if you're in process, where it's like you feel like you've done all the things that you're not good at.
继续前进，因为这意味着你离你擅长的事情更近了。哦，太对了。当你在那里的那一刻，心流，就像，你会知道的。人们总是问，我怎么会知道？那是不可否认的。那是不可否认的。就像，你会知道的，因为那种感觉就像你可以把你的整个人生都投入到做这些活动中。是的。
Keep going because it means that you're closer to the thing that you are good at. Oh, so, so true. Like, when you get there, the flows, like, you will know. People always like, how will I know? It's undeniable. It's undeniable. Like, you will know because it will just feel like you could, you could live your entire life in the time that you spend doing these activities. Yeah.
事情是这样的。它并不总是与工作有关。完全正确。而且我认为我们确实感到了把我们所做的一切都货币化的巨大压力，正如你所说的那样。就像把这作为你的爱好感觉很神圣。把它当作你的爱好。此外，如果你不想在白天的工作中做有意义的工作，因为你想为自己保留这些，那就去做吧，对吧？对于“足够好的工作”，有很多话要说。所以目标不一定非得是我们的工作。我们不一定非得有一份有意义的工作。我们不必把一切都变成我们的职业。我认为听到这一点非常重要，因为这不是我开始的方式。
And here's the thing. It doesn't always have to do, have to be about. about work. Exactly. And I think that we do feel so much pressure to monetize everything that we do and exactly what you said. It's like it feels sacred to keep it as your hobby. Keep it as your hobby. Also, if you don't want to do purposeful work in your day job because you want to keep that for yourself, do that, right? There's so much to be said for the good enough job. And so purpose doesn't have to be our job. We don't have to have to have the purposeful job. We don't have to turn everything into our careers. I think that's so important to hear because that's not how I started.
我总是对人们说，如果你想把你的爱好变成职业，你绝对必须200%地热爱它。因为一旦你开始从某件事中赚钱，你就会少爱它很多。所以你要确保你仍然尽可能多地爱它。我有一个像这样的朋友，她总是说，我真的不在乎我的工作是什么。我的生活存在于工作之外。我的生活存在于我的人际关系和日常生活中。我只是，我只是在选择那份我认为可以用最少努力赚最多钱的工作。这样我就可以去玩了。
I always say to people, if you want to make a career out of your hobby, you most certainly have to love it 200%. Because the moment you start making money from something, you're going to love it a whole lot less. So you want to make sure you're still loving it as much as you can. I have a friend who's like this and she's like, I don't really care what my job is. My life exists outside of my job. My life exists in my relationships and in my day to day. I just, I'm just choosing the job that I think I can make the most money from the least amount of effort from. so I can go and have fun.
我就觉得，太棒了。而且那个女人，我爱她。她休病假。她休事假。就像，她根本不在乎。我觉得，那是一个保持一致的生活。那是充满目的的野心，对吧？完全正确。
And I was like, great. And that woman, I love her. She uses her sick leave. She uses her personal leave. Like, she does not give an F. And I'm like, that is, that is an aligned life. That is purposeful ambition, right? Exactly.
她过着非常一致的生活。真为她高兴。我还有一个最后的问题。这和野心完全没有关系。实际上，这是我们在每集结束时都会问每位客人的问题。对于20多岁的年轻人，你有什么建议？这与我们今天谈论的内容完全无关。我想说，虽然间接相关，但就是尽可能多地玩。
She is living a beautifully aligned life. Good for her. I've got one final question for you. And it has nothing to do with ambition. Actually, it's the question we ask every single guest at the end of the episode. What is one piece of advice that you have for people in their 20s? That is nothing to do with what we spoke about today. I would say, like, it's related tangentially, but like have as much fun as possible.
我认为结合我们刚才所说的，我们在20多岁的时候感受到了做所有这些事情和实现所有这些成就的压力，但是乐趣呢？对吧？就像你的关节可能永远不会像在20多岁时那样好了，对吧？所以，去做户外的事情，和你的朋友去度假。去做那些给你带来最多快乐的事情。我觉得我们只是埋头苦干，工作太努力了。
I think that connected to what we were saying, we feel all of this pressure to do all of these things and achieve all of these things in our 20s, but like what about the fun, right? It's like your joints will never be as good as they are in their 20s probably, right? So like, you know, do the thing that's outside, like go on vacation with your friends. Like, do the thing that brings you the most joy. Like I think that we just put our heads down and work too hard. we miss the fun and then we look back and we're so nostalgic and it's like I had it so good why didn't I take advantage and so thank as much as you can just really have fun oh I love that advice
我们错过了乐趣，然后我们回首往事时是如此怀念，心想我当时过得太好了，为什么我没有好好利用，所以尽可能多地享受乐趣，真正去玩吧。哦，我喜欢这个建议。
that's actually good I needed to hear this today I was going to sit in and I was going to sit in my hotel room and work all day and I think I'm going to go do go for a run I'm going to go explore in your face I'm going to go play yeah I love that well I'm going to thank you so much for coming on the podcast this felt like a very soulfully aligned conversation and what I really needed to hear where can everyone find your book because I think it's essential reading. Thank you so much for having me. This was one of my most fun conversations and I love how you related everything to what you're going through, what your listeners are going through.
这真的很好，我今天正需要听到这个。我原本打算坐在酒店房间里工作一整天，我想我今天要出去跑步了。我要去探索你的脸。我要去玩。是的，我很喜欢这样。非常感谢你来到这个播客。这感觉像是一次灵魂契合的对话，也是我真正需要听到的。大家在哪里可以找到你的书，因为我认为这是必读读物。非常感谢邀请我。这是我最有趣的对话之一，我喜欢你如何将一切与你正在经历的、你的听众正在经历的事情联系起来。
It just makes it so much more fun to participate in. So thank you. And you can find the book everywhere books are sold. So whether that's your favorite indie bookstore, they can order it for you or a national retailer. It is available everywhere. And it is also has a beautiful cover, I will say. I have a copy, not with me, but.
这让参与其中变得有趣得多。所以谢谢你。你可以在所有出售图书的地方找到这本书。无论是你最喜欢的独立书店，他们可以为你订购，还是全国零售商。它随处可见。而且它也有一个美丽的封面，我要说的是。我有一本副本，虽然不在身边，但在
at my house and I had someone over the other day who picked it up and they're like, this is a beautiful book cover. Oh, thank you. Yeah, and I was like, it's a good book as well. I think she took it home with her. But I'll make sure that that is super accessible for you guys to find. I hope you enjoyed this episode.
我家，前几天有人拿起来看，他们说，这是一个漂亮的封面。哦，谢谢。是的，我当时说，这也是一本好书。我想她把它带回家了。但我会确保你们能超级容易地找到它。希望你喜欢这一集。
I hope it's reframed something for you in terms of ambition or success, especially in our 20s. Sometimes it is just a reminder that we need to hear. Make sure that you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast and that you're following us here on Spotify, Apple, IHeart, wherever you are listening to help the show grow and reach new people. And so you know when new episodes are coming out. But until next time, stay safe, be kind.
我希望它在雄心或成功方面为您重新构架了一些东西，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候。有时这只是一个我们需要听到的提醒。请确保在 Instagram 上关注我（@thatpsychologyg），并在 Spotify、Apple、IHeart 或任何你收听的地方关注我们，以帮助节目成长并触及更多人，这样你也能知道新节目什么时候发布。但直到下次，注意安全，保持善良。
Maybe be a little bit less ambitious today. Be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness,
也许今天可以稍微少一点雄心壮志。对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会交谈。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理坚韧的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
体能，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是 IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 2%。在 Look Back at it 播客上。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
对 1979 年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何在朋友、同仁喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士交谈。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of first. fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and.
而且仅仅因为你有能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控首先。生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和。
Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast,
他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe.”。这是一个 IHeart 播客，
guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是由人类制作的。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。